[Music]
in the time of the accomplished emperor
tai sung the illustrious and magnificent
founder of the dynasty
among the enlightened and holy men who
arrived was the most virtuous olopon
from the country of syria
observing the azure clouds he bore the
true sacred books beholding the
direction of the winds he braved
difficulties and dangers
in the year a.d 635 he arrived at
chang-an
the emperor sent his prime minister who
carrying the official staff to the west
border
conducted his guest into the interior
the sacred books were translated in the
imperial library the sovereign
investigated the subject in his private
apartments
when becoming deeply impressed with the
rectitude and truth of the religion he
gave special orders for its
dissemination
in the seventh month of the year ad638
the following imperial proclamation was
issued
[Music]
right principles have no invariable name
holy men have no invariable station
instruction is the object of benefiting
the people at large
the greatly virtuous olopon of the
kingdom of syria has brought his sacred
books and images from that distant part
and has presented them at our chief
capital having examined the principles
of this religion we find them to be
purely excellent and natural
investigating its originating source we
find it has taken its rise from the
establishment of important truths
its ritual is free from perplexing
expressions its principles will survive
when the framework is forgotten
it is beneficial to all creatures it is
advantageous to mankind
let it be published throughout the
empire and let the proper authority
build a syrian church in the capital
which shall be governed by 21 priests
this video is sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service
question when was jesus born a the year
0
b between 4 and 6 a d
c between 4 and 6 b c
and d
100 a d
[Music]
yes that's correct most biblical
scholars assume a birthday between 4 and
6 bc about the same time emperor eye of
han ascended to the throne and so my
recommendation this week from magellan's
exhaustive collection is the bible a
history 4k which over six episodes tries
to unpack the truth behind the biblical
stories and how the people in it are
viewed today personally i'm fascinated
by how ancient cultures interpreted
their stories and this is a great look
at that
so click on the link in the description
for an exclusive month-long free trial
for voices of the past viewers
thanks
[Music]
when the joe dynasty declined the rider
on the azure ox ascended to the west the
principles of the great tongue becoming
resplendent
the illustrious breezes have come to fan
the east
according to the illustrated memoir of
the western regions and the historical
books of the han and wei dynasties the
kingdom of syria reaches south to the
coral sea
on the north it joins the gem mountains
on the west it extends towards the
borders of the immortals and the flowery
forests on the east it lies open to the
violent winds and tideless waters the
country produces fireproof cloth
life restoring incense bright moon
pearls and night luster gems
brigands and robbers are unknown but the
people enjoy happiness and peace
none but illustrious laws prevail none
but the virtuous are raised to sovereign
power
the land is broad and ample and its
literary productions are perspicuous and
clear
[Music]
27 sacred books have been left which
disseminate intelligence by unfolding
the original transforming principles by
the rule for admission it is the custom
to apply the water of baptism to wash
away all superficial show and to cleanse
and purify the neophytes as a seal they
hold the cross whose influence is
reflected in every direction uniting all
without distinction as they strike the
wood the fame of their benevolence is
diffused abroad worshiping toward the
east they hasten on the way to life and
glory they preserve the beard to
symbolize their outward actions they
shave the crown to indicate the absence
of inward affections they do not keep
slaves but put noble and mean on all
equality they do not amass wealth but
cast all their property into the common
stock they fast in order to perfect
themselves by self-inspection they
submit to restraints in order to
strengthen themselves by silent
watchfulness
seven times a day they have worship and
praise for the benefit of the living and
the dead
once in seven days they sacrifice
to cleanse the heart and return to
purity
[Music]
behold the unchangeably true and
invisible
who existed throughout all eternity
without origin whose mysterious
existence is everlasting operating on
primordial substance he created the
universe being more excellent than all
holy intelligences inasmuch as he is the
source of all that is honorable
this is our eternal true lord god
mysterious in substance
he appointed the cross as the means for
determining the four cardinal points
he moved the original spirit and
produced the two principles of nature
the somber void was changed and heaven
and earth were opened out
the sun and moon revolved and day and
night commenced having perfected all
inferior objects he then made the first
man upon him he bestowed an excellent
disposition giving him the government of
all created beings man acting out the
original principles of his nature was
pure and unostentatious his unsullied
and expansive mind was free from the
least inordinate desire
until satan introduced the seeds of
falsehood to deteriorate his purity the
opening thus commenced in his virtue
gradually enlarged and by this crevice
in his nature he was obscured and
rendered vicious
365 sects followed each other in
continuous track inventing every species
of doctrine while some pointed to
material objects as the source of their
faith others reduced all to vacancy some
sought to cool down blessings by prayers
and supplications
while others by an assumption of
excellence held themselves up as
superior to their fellows
they never obtained their vast desires
and lost their path and after long
groping in darkness they were unable to
return
thereupon our trinity being divided in
nature the illustrious and honorable
messiah veiling his true dignity
appeared in the world as a man
[Music]
angelic powers promulgated the glad
tidings a virgin gave birth to the holy
one in syria
a bright star announced the event and
persians observing the splendor came to
present tribute
the ancient dispensation as declared by
the 24 holy men was then fulfilled and
he laid down great principles for the
government of families and kingdoms
he established the new religion of the
silent operation of the pure spirit of
the triune he rendered virtue
subservient to direct faith he fixed the
extent of the eight boundaries thus
completing the truth and freeing it from
dross he opened the gate of the three
constant principles introducing life and
destroying death
he set in motion the vessel of mercy by
which to ascend to the bright mansions
whereupon rational beings were then
released having thus completed the
manifestation of his power
in clear day he ascended to his true
station
it is difficult to find a name to
express the excellence of the true and
unchangeable doctrine but as its
operations are manifestly displayed by
accommodation it is named the
illustrious
religion
now without holy men principles cannot
become expanded without principles holy
men cannot become magnified but with
holy men and right principles united as
the two parts of a signet
the world becomes civilized
and enlightened
the emperor khao zang respectively
succeeded his ancestor and was still
more beneficent towards the institution
of truth in every province he caused
illustrious churches to be erected and
ratified the honor conferred upon olopon
making him the great conservator of
doctrine for the preservation of the
state while this doctrine pervaded every
channel the state became enriched and
tranquility abounded
every city was full of churches and the
royal family enjoyed lustre and
happiness
in the year ad699 the buddhists gaining
power raised their voices in the eastern
metropolis
in the year
ad713 some low fellows excited ridicule
and spread slanders in the western
capital at that time there was the chief
priest lohan and others of noble estate
from the golden regions
lofty-minded priests having abandoned
all worldly interests who unitedly
maintained the grand principles and
preserved them entire to the end
in 744 the priest ki ho in the kingdom
of syria looked towards the star of
china
was attracted by its transforming
influence and observing the sun
came to pay court to the most honorable
thereupon the emperor composed mottos
for the sides of the church and the
tablets were graced with royal
inscriptions
the accumulated gems emitted their
effulgence while the sparkling
brightness vied with the ruby clouds
the transcripts of intelligence
suspended in the void shot forth their
rays as reflected by the sun the
bountiful gifts exceeded the height of
the southern hills the bedewing favours
were deep as the eastern seas
the accomplished and enlightened emperor
sutsung rebuilt the illustrious churches
in lingwoo and four other places great
benefits were conferred and felicity
began to increase great munificence was
displayed and the imperial state became
established by extended commiseration
rescuing multitudes from misery while
disseminating blessings on all around
the cultivation of our doctrine gained a
grand basis and by gradual advances its
influence was diffused if the winds and
rains are seasonable the world will be
at rest
men will be guided by principle the
living will be at ease and the dead will
rejoice
the thoughts will produce their
appropriate response and the eyes will
be sincere
such is the laudable condition which we
of the illustrious religion are laboring
to attain
you